salut a tous voila je vais vous dire que
je viens juste d'avoir un appel de
l'équipe du film lucky qui m'a dit voilà
on adorerait qu'il soit présente aux
avant premières du film en belgique
j'ai effectivement eu les avant
premières vous allez voir le qui c'est
un film dans lequel ge est l'un des
rôles principaux
enfin l'un des principaux rôles qu'on ne
voit que quelques minutes à l'écran
alors bien sûr vous vous êtes sûrement
comme moi quel dommage quel gâchis donc
j'ai évidemment posé la question au
réalisateur
je lui ai dit pourquoi ma mort d un si
petit rôle dans un film qui l'est il m'a
dit ne remet pas du tout en fait c'est
parce que ton jeu est tellement
incroyable tellement puissant que si on
avait misé plus longtemps dans le film
tu aurais passé tous les autres acteurs
totalement inaperçu finalement donc je
dis ok ok pour le petit rôle il a uni os
la prochaine fois si tu veux un plus
grand rôle dans mes films il faut que tu
as baisse ton niveau de jeu pts au
niveau des autres acteurs et la gym
excuse moi je tâte je vais pas brader
mon talent pour jouer dans des films de
merde parce que toi tout à fait quoi en
fait je sais à quoi tu avais dit que nec
j'ai dit que n'est qu' on en effet des
caisses un film culte des millions de
vues virement honnêtement là où
j'habitais en belgique personne n'avait
dit connaître en resterait que dans le
raid visant ni la télé ni l'excès mais
c'est juste pour des questions
d'écologie
j'ai dit après j'ai comme une deuxième
petite question parce que d'accord pour
les petits rôles mais tandis que nec
marion cotillard mélanie laurent jeux
paraissent elles sont quand même plutôt
mignonne j'ai alors pourquoi moi dans
son nouveau film
pourquoi m'avoir fait cette gueule
est ce que c'est une vengeance
personnelle est-ce que je traînais ta
mère de [ __ ] dans mes sketches parce que
totalement le genre de truc que je
pourrais faire un métier pas ouais c'est
la vie on s'insulte pour rien on voit là
on sait pas pourquoi êtes vous repasse
au-dessus en fait c'est juste la vie
c'est pas la peine je dirais c'est
tellement important une entrée au cinéma
prêter canal est ok tu vois moi avec
cette gueule la laisse tomber après pour
jouer le biopic de monica bellucci alors
en plus moi je vais vous dire
honnêtement ce que j'en pense parce que
moi j'ai vu le tournage de lucky et je
vous dira honnêtement il n'y a vraiment
rien de pros sur le stage de qui j'ai
pas on est sonné xxème siècle c'est du
cinéma
pas un viol pas une remarque misogynie
pas une remarque déplacée
notre monde est gentil tout monde et
poli bonjour comment allez vous et bien
prenez un café asseyez-vous non mais j'y
mec personne va parler de ton film en
fait comment tu veux qu'on en parle en
plus ce n'est pas il y avait un chien il
y avait un gosse il va être un moyen de
faire un scandale un petit peu original
n'ont rien à [ __ ] le mec je dis
personne n'en a parlé un petit peu c'est
quoi moi les petites affiches comme ça
qu'ils prennent la grosse tête
j'ai même pas envie de les voir à mes
premières tag rester chez toi je dis
ouais mais je vois très bien ce que tu
es en train d'essayer de faire la paix
en train d'essayer de m'évincer de thé
[ __ ] d'avant-premières pour que je
veuille pas encore la vedette à tout le
monde et pour convainc pas encore que de
moi alors c'est quoi j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] je serai là à t [ __ ]
d'avant-premières connard
[Musique]